en 1905 albert einstein qui était alors
complètement encore inconnue va écrire
sur un bout de papier une équation qui
va devenir la plus connue et la plus
jolie équation de toute l'histoire de la
physique la fameuse équation e égal m
fois c'est carré mais que signifie cette
équation ian mc carey pourquoi einstein
l'a écrite et surtout pourquoi est ce
que les autres n'ont accepté mais
aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous parler de
tout ça et de vous faire comprendre
quelque chose que j'ai mis beaucoup
beaucoup de temps à comprendre à savoir
le sens profond de cette équation le
gall mc pour commencer il faut savoir
qu'un chanut et approuvé cette équation
il a déduit cette équation d'une
hypothèse incroyablement lumineuse est
simple savoir l'hypothèse selon laquelle
la vitesse de la lumière est absolu et
c'est complètement fou de se dire que
l'hypothèse selon laquelle la vitesse de
la lumière la même pour tous impliquent
l'équation e gala mc quarrie c'est juste
fou et ce qui est encore plus fou c'est
que la démonstration n'est pas si
compliqué et en gros on va pouvoir
parler des grandes lignes en tout cas de
cette démonstration dans une vidéo cinq
forums imaginons sheldon avec un double
sabre laser sont bons quand il allume
deux rayons de lumière parts à l'infini
l'ensemble sheldon plus sabre laser père
alors l'énergie eu des deux rayons de
lumière
notons de plus que dans son référentiel
tout est alors symétrique
il n'y a donc aucune raison qu'ils se
mettent à se déplacer vers la droite
plutôt que vers la gauche et on conclut
donc que sheldon reste immobile
du coup dans tous les référentiels la
vitesse de sheldon reste inchangé
ajoutons maintenant leonarda cette
expérience de pensée
supposons que pour commencer les dans le
même référentiel que sheldon puis il se
met à courir vers sheldon atteint 8 sv
voix sheldon allumer son sabre laser
puis s'arrête devant sheldon
dans les référentiels successives de
leonardo c'est leonardo qui est immobile
et sheldon qui va acquérir une vitesse
ainsi léonard bois à sheldon qui gagne
une énergie cinétique puis père
l'énergie des rayons de lumière puis
perd son énergie cinétique
a priori tout va bien sauf que dans le
référentiel de léonarde sheldon est donc
la source de lumière sont en mouvement
et ça à cause de l'effet doppler
relativiste cannes stein avait déduit de
l'hypothèse selon laquelle la vitesse de
la lumière est la même pour tous ça veut
dire que les rayons de lumière émis par
le sabre laser de sheldon ne vont plus
avoir la même énergie le rayon de
lumière qui va vers léonard devait être
plus bleue et emporté plus d'énergie
tandis que le rayon qui s'éloigne de
losne world va lui emporté moins
d'énergie mais si on ajoute les énergies
des deux rayons ont conclu que l'énergie
emporté par les deux rayons de lumière
est plus grande dans le référentiel de
léonarde que dans celui de sheldon
or le bilan de l'énergie perdue par
sheldon et son sabre laser doit être le
même dans le référentiel de sheldon
comme dans celui de leonardo quelle
conclusion inéluctable d'einstein et que
l'énergie cinétique de sheldon était
plus grande
avant l'allumage du double sabre laser
qu'après puis ça ça peut paraître débile
puisque l'on a dit que la vitesse v de
sheldon restent inchangés lors de
l'allumage du sabre laser or l'énergie
cinétique et 1/2 de mv carré donc si
l'énergie cinétique avant était plus
grande qu après c'est donc forcément
parce que l'âme mast sheldon et de son
sabre laser a diminué au moment de
l'émission des rayons de lumière
dans l'ancien de léonarde la variation
de masse la masse perdu par sheldon et
son sabre-laser est égale à deux fois le
ou l énergie est emporté par les rayons
de lumière dans le référentiel de
sheldon fois dans ce bidule qui fait
intervenir la vitesse de sheldon dans le
référentiel de leonardo et vitesse c'est
de la lumière et donc ce que l'on voit
dans cette équation c'est que sheldon et
son sabre laser perdre un petit peu de
masse et que cette masse perdu dépend du
référentiel depuis lequel on regarde
shannon maintenant que nous intéressant
le plus c'est de voir quelle est la
masse perdu par sheldon selon lui et ça
pour ça suffit de prendre la limite de
tout ça lorsque vais t'en vers zéro
parti qu on peut faire des pubs pour
limiter ces scans china faire son papier
original et sort ce qu'on fait ça et 20
ans tombe sur la fameuse équation m est
égal à eux sur ces carrés qui est
d'ailleurs la vraie équation navré
équation c'est pareil il a le secret
cn est égal à eux sur ces carrés bon
bien sûr ces deux équations 20 qui
vendent mais je pense qui est super
important de l'écrire m est égal à eux
sur ces carrés car le message que l'on
envoie quand on écrit m est égal à eux
sur ces carrés n'est pas le même que si
on écrit un gala mc carey ici m est égal
à eux sur ces carrés dit que la masse
perdu par sheldon et l'énergie qu'il a
perdu / c'est carré c'est une définition
de ce qu'est la masse perdu ce n'est pas
du tout une façon de définir de
l'énergie en particulier un son sourd
des mauvaises interprétations de
l'équation e égal mc carey on entend
souvent dire par exemple que la masse
est une forme d'énergie ou que la masse
peut être convertie en énergie ou kylie
à équivalence entre massey energy
tout ça c'est assez faux je suis pas du
tout en train de dire ça pour dénigrer
stigmatiser ou condamner ceux qui le
disent
il ya des gens très bien qui dit ça a de
même des gens géniaux ans qui dit c'est
tout je suis fan mais qui dit c'est un
peu à la va vite dans une phrase c'est
pas grave alors de dire ça c'est si on
veut parler de la relativité générale et
ont dit deux phrases comme ça
au détour d'une phrase c'est pas grave
je ne condamne pas du tout ces gens là
au contraire je trouve que c'est génial
ce qu'ils font et que s'il ya des
petites imprécisions c'est pas c'est pas
grave du tout pas grave du tout si je
vous dis ça aujourd'hui c'est à des fins
pédagogiques j'essaie de vous faire
comprendre le vrai sens de l'équation
égale mc carey et pour y arriver c'est
utile de montrer que des façons de
parler que l'on a de la physique
d'einstein ne seront pas valides et ne
sont pas conformes à ce que einstein lui
dit il alors que dit vraiment l'équation
e égal mc carey pour bien comprendre
cette équation
il nous faut d'abord comprendre le
concept de masse la masse en tout cas
celle qui étudie à stein dans son papier
de novembre 1905 à ce sujet c'est
l'inertie
cette inertie mesure la résistance des
objets à voir leur vitesse modifiée de
façon grossière la masse inertielle est
alors la quantité d'énergie qu'il faut
ajouter ou retirer à un corps pour
modifier sa vitesse de 10 km h ou plus
pour illustrer ceci
imaginons que je me jette sur sébastien
chabal très probablement ne bougera pas
d'un poil quand moi je tomberai par
terre si je n'ai pas pu a fêté son
mouvement c'est parce que chabal possède
une très grande inertie toute l'énergie
cinétique de mouvement ne suffit pas à
le faire reculer
al'inverse mouvement aura été
complètement arrêté car mon nid merci
bien plus faible que celle de chamarré
noter que dans ce raisonnement la
gravité n'intervient pas du tout plu ce
que je viens de dire reste vrai si je
percute chabal dans l'espace
intergalactique
d'ailleurs la gravité sera elle aussi
complètement repensé par einstein en
1915 n'y viendra mais pas tout de suite
bref ce que dit einstein c'est qu'un
objet qui a absorbé beaucoup d'énergie
va acquérir beaucoup d'inertie l'inertie
est une complète et émergentes d'une
accumulation d'énergie
en fait ce qu'einstein a réussi à faire
en disant ceci s'est déterminé la cause
de l'inertie d'inertie n'est plus une
propriété fondamentale est intrinsèque
des objets qui nous entourent
c'est maintenant une conséquence du fait
que ces objets sont des concentrations
d'énergie et le plus fou c'est cannes
stein à 18 tout ça de la seule hypothèse
selon laquelle la vitesse de la lumière
est absolument incroyable et donc par
exemple l'inertie de mon corps mon i
merci elle vient d'où avait uniquement
de l'énergie que j'ai réussi à
emprisonner à l'aide de mon corps cette
énergie en fait elle vient
essentiellement à 98 pour 99% du chant
mieux onic du champ de la force forte
que les quarks des nucléons des noyaux
des atomes des cellules des tissus de
mon corps ont su emprisonnés s'il se
trouve tout ce que je suis en fait c'est
de l'énergie du chant des grillons
emprisonné à 98 3 9%
le % restants ayant été découverts selon
des années après einstein dans les
années 60 par peter hayes qui donne de
la masse différemment aux électrons au
qwark et au boson w z
mais ce mécanisme de higgs dont on a
tellement entendu parler au cours des
dernières années fait il est à fond dans
ce land 1 2% de la masse de nos corps
très très très peu quoi le gros de la
masse c'est de l'énergie du champ des
lions qui ont marre et 6 emprisonné
c'est luca gonzi ça je vous renvoie à ce
sujet vers l'excellente vidéo de veritas
y sommes et vous renvoie aussi sur
l'excellente vidéo de psp stein sur ian
mc carey sur l'origine de la masse de la
matière je vous renvoie aussi vers le
papier aux originales d'albert einstein
qui est vraiment laid
libre il ne fait que trois pages et il
est vraiment pas si compliqué est
vraiment compréhensible pour un papier
de physique théorique dont le titre je
rappelle awad c est ce que l'inertie
d'un corps dépend de l'énergie qui
contient qui est vraiment le message clé
d'einstein d'avoir la fin du papier il
dit bien que la masse est vraiment
qu'une mesure de l'énergie d'un corps
qui contenu dans un corps et le génie
d'einstein avec cette équation c'est
qu'il a proposé une façon de tester
directement son équation en imaginant
des particules radioactives dans le cnsl
de radium et il s'est dit que si elles
émettent des rayonnements lumineux c'est
que leur masse doivent forcément
diminuer et ça c'est tout le génie d'un
chêne avoir pensé à tout ça j'espère que
j'ai été à peu près incompréhensible
dans cette histoire j'espère aussi que
ça va vraiment révolutionner votre
vision de ce qu'est la masse de pourquoi
est ce que les objets sont difficiles à
bouger car moi c'est complètement
retourné l'esprit tu constater qu'en
fait tout ce qui est masque tout ce qui
est résistant ce mouvement est en fait
juste de l'énergie emprisonnée elle vous
invite vraiment réfléchir la phrase la
masse peut être transformée en énergie
ou quelque chose comme ça et d'essayer
de comprendre par vous même pourquoi je
pense que c'est complètement faux
pourquoi ai je ne suis pas le seul à
penser ça les physiciens théoriciens
bien plus intelligente mois le pensent
aussi que j'espère que vous avez mais
cette vidéo et que vous allez vraiment
méditer le sens de ce qu'est la masse
par ailleurs printemps et reçu aucune
réponse par rapport aux défilés je vous
invite vraiment essayé d'y réfléchir et
essayer de le résoudre c'est un point
très intéressant par la prochaine fois
je donnerai la solution à cette cet
exercice et ça va me permettre aussi de
parler les diagrammes de minto ce type
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo va
partager la vie telle à un pouce vers le
fait vraiment parce que
par la chaîne a vraiment du mal à
décoller et j'aimerais bien que ça
décolle un petit peu plus
mettez vos commentaires vos questions ci
dessous il essaiera d'y répondre à la
prochaine fois s'il y avait de bonnes
questions et j'espère que je voudrais la
prochaine fois